all right now let's do another example
it seems like it's just as simple i'm
gonna get rid of this
but it'll it'll highlight the problem of
using these t results and what we have
to do to overcome it
instead of cos x is equal to zero
let's solve
sine x
is equal to zero do it in the same
domain
okay so just like before you say let t
equal you have to introduce it
bring in variables without telling what
they are yeah question
okay sure it comes back to you yeah is
the problem the um
yes that's right and come out in a
second
just like before i'm going to note down
this adjusted domain good pickup by the
way so it's now between
sorry
one pi okay
all right now therefore let's remember
this is the result for cos so the result
for sine
wrack your brains it's the other two
sides in the triangle
do you need like some washington or
something you sound like you've got some
problems
yeah okay great yes that's the result
all right so
that's equal to zero
okay
now you look at this and you're like wow
this is even easier than before two t
equals zero so t is equal to zero so tan
of x or two
is equal to zero and you think about
what tan looks like and remember i'm
solving from zero to pi
right where are the two places that tan
is zero well kind of looks like this
right
okay this is from naught to pi if i went
to two pi i'd get another lot of that
right
so where are my solutions for zero here
at zero and here at pi
right so x on 2 is 0 or pi
so therefore you multiply through and
you get two solutions just like before
so that looks good right
so just like we did with the cosine
question let's just double check that
what does sine look like
sine looks like this
all right and we're solving for when
it's equal to zero so the solutions
we've got so far are zero
check
two pie
check
right okay
we missed the solution poor old pie left
in the middle just like the third child
that was me what's what's the matter
with this solution why why didn't it
appear
why didn't just like we didn't you can
check the algebra there's nothing wrong
with the algebra there's nothing that
you like um
you cancel that you shouldn't cancel
that it's all correct
what's the problem
well here's the um here's the problem
uh let's um let me do this
okay the problem with t results no
matter what kind of setup you've got
whatever kind of equations right
is that
x can never equal pi
never ever ever ever or any multiple pi
for when it comes to when it comes to it
why not
because
this whole way of solving things right
it depends on tan oh okay tan of x on
two but tan as you can see by this
triangle right it's got some problems
right
tan
doesn't exist
at pi on 2 right there's an asymptote
there it doesn't exist at 3 pi on 2 it
doesn't exist at 5 pi on 2 and so on and
so on and so on right
so remember
this is x on 2 right so x on 2 can't
equal pi on 2
right it can never equal until you're
just your calculator will melt down okay
so if x on 2 can't equal pi over 2
therefore you just multiply 3 by 2 and
you get this result ok
so
what does it mean okay
um
you've been talking about how sometimes
you can solve a question um one way or
another right and i've been telling you
okay choose the best way choose
whichever works out best
occasionally they will say solve this
and use this specific method if you
remember back to last year
i don't know if you remember there was a
particular formula you learned
for if you've got
corner geometry okay you have two lines
and they intersect and then there's some
third point over here and you have to
find the equation
of the line that is
co-linear way
concurrent concurrent there's two other
lines and goes through that point okay
you can solve this a variety of ways but
there was one way you learned your 10
called the k method does that ring any
bells like even if you don't remember
how to do it right
now the thing is sometimes the question
said
buy the k method do this right even
though it's perfectly fine to do it the
other way it took a bit longer
and exactly the same way sometimes
they'll say by the t results show this
okay
even if they don't stipulate it right
um whatever you do once you get to the
end you must test
x equals pi okay what does that mean
you go back to your original equation
and you sub pi you see what happens
right so in this case you get sine of pi
that equals zero right which satisfies
the equation you started with so you say
therefore pi or x equals pi
is one of the solutions right so you add
it in with the other two that you got
you get three solutions right over here
even though you might know like it it's
not going to be x equals pi you still
are obliged to test x equals pi
okay you must do it because the problem
with t results is it always misses this
solution okay so therefore you say okay
sub it into here
cos of pi
what's cos of pi equal to it's going to
be i haven't drawn it i've dropped it
off it's going to be minus one okay so
it's not a solution so great it's fine i
don't need to worry about it okay
but here's the big thing you need to
write in bold put big red rectangles
around and all that kind of thing
when you use the t results to solve
a trig equation like these okay you must
test x equals pi every single time okay
now i told you before
that this isn't the only place the
problem occurs right it actually goes
over here as well and it'll occur again
it'll occur an infinite number of times
so
why do we only have to test x equals pi
why don't we have to test any other
values of x
any thoughts
well where was the next time this
problem came up the next time the
problem comes up is it three pi over two
right so
x on two is equal to that so it would
miss the solution x equals three pi
but three pi isn't in the domain right
and it usually isn't okay
this is the most common domain you get
the second most common domain you get is
minus pi
to pi
i think
once
in an exercise written by a certain very
thorough head teacher have i seen a
question go out to this domain apart
from that exams you never see it it's
always going to be in one of these two
domains basically okay so that's why we
say test x equals pi if the question was
a freak of nature and it's like yeah
let's solve it from four pi to um
to six pi or something like that you'd
have to test
five pi because that's the odd one it's
just right in between okay but um but
that's that's rubbish i've never seen a
question okay so x equals pi that's the
one you've got to test